how do you make something last a
thousand years because that is a long
period of time there are very few human
endeavors they've lasted and millennium
the buildings behind me
I'm designed to last that long a century
perhaps before they're raised and
redeveloped with something else the
Great Pyramid of Giza that's lasted
incredible long time are there in
universities who can trace back nearly a
thousand years as a construction company
in Japan that started in five seven
eightt AD and went into liquidation a
few years but if you have a project that
wants to last that long well you're not
gonna be alive to see it through I mean
we can hope that life extension
technologies will come along but right
now humans don't live much past a
hundred years so what do you do if your
project requires a thousand well behind
me is long player inside Trinity boy
Wharf lighthouse here in London long
player is a music composition for seeing
bowls designed to last 1,000 years from
the start of 2000 to the end of to 999
and that is an incredibly long time in
order for that to work it doesn't have a
person that sees it through it has to be
a corporation in this case a non-profit
a charity something called the long
player trust whose job it is to keep the
composition going right now it's being
synthesized by a computer there's a
large instrument in there that it's in
the process of being completed and the
Trust's job is this update the computer
when it needs updating port the software
to another language written in
supporting find replacements of the
people on the long player trust board
when they need replacing so that in nine
hundred and eighty something years
whether it's here or somewhere else or
if the sea levels rise another city or
country entirely you will still be able
to hear long-player somewhere in the
world that is how you make something
last a thousand years you use many
people and an entity designed to last
that long which is a corporation which
is something you might not have known